wer weiß schon von morgen sind
jeden tag das sind
wer
heute morgen sind immer wieder aufs neue
beginnt so wir sind heute im
alpenvorland und stellen eine alte
bayerische tradition vornehmlich das
kursziel schleusten keine ahnung wie man
das auf hochdeutsch ausspricht ganz
würde sagen das macht nix ist politisch
und eine große list was es da also eine
peitsche quasi und was macht man damit
beim kreuzen
ursprünglich ist es werkzeug meer treibt
damit periode wozu keine lkws geben ein
warnsignal war es früher auch noch wenn
man mit
trotz gespannter kurve fährt nach der
anderen gegen kommt das arbeitsgerät und
mit den kursen kommen die robert winkler
den winter vertrieb die bösen geister
respekt mal wird es ein problem dass ich
das auch mal ausprobieren
doch die anfänge der müllerwiese
motorradhelm auf motorradhelmen hast du
zufällig ein okay dann lassen wir das
mal lieber
könnt ihr mir was zeigen ziel ist dass
du mit dem stück vorne liegende acht max
und immer war der wendepunkt ist von den
auch dann muss von hand so eine
schneiderei machen und dann schnalzt
eigentlich da an dieser ecke
das war knapp das ist das was eigentlich
normalerweise braucht man das
einigermaßen und wie habe ich mich jetzt
so angestellt
impress wie lange hat es so tradition
des börsen heute ewig tradition nur die
kombi mit der musik ist also 1960 was
zeigen
wir müssen mit eiskunstlauf werke ag
montierten wir gehen unsere eigenen
stücken kühe letzte saison wo ist das
open gibt probleme das wichtigste in
bayern wenn man irgendwas macht
kartenspielen fußballspielen gastes 19
wenn man sich trifft muss eins dabei
sein
das steht hier bald mal wieder ich
probiere das jetzt noch mal aus und dann
schaue mal ob ich da irgendwie mitmachen
darf bei der nächsten meisterschaft